we had autumnal vibes
what a perfect place to fall in love
lots of women to be
buzzing about we got the glow stick
going
and we met matt i'm starting to feel it
it's starting to feel real
this is your the bachelor season 25
episode 1 matt james's premiere recap
grab your glasses
it's time for roses and rose
hi everybody it's me lauren zema
and we're back in a hat
oh babes it is matt james's premiere
the bachelor season 25 premiere
the first ever black bachelor premiere
so much to celebrate so happy to be back
with you
so we are gonna toast with a little
champs
we're also toasting with champagne
because matt's season is
filmed in pennsylvania in the fall with
the chili vibes that's why i'm wearing
this hat
so i just love a champagne like in the
cold the leaves are changing or
maybe they've already fallen down to the
ground and you're just feeling cozy and
wonderful
anyway i'm already in a fantasy i gotta
get back to reality
cheers to matt james
no fizz is that a good sign or bad
winter's air it's gone lauren stop
by the way how are you babes how is
everyone how were your holidays
your new years and what did you all
think of this premiere i honestly
thought it was one of the best season
premieres we've had in some time we had
nice emotional real conversations
i never really saw an example of what
love
was like mixed in with some fun messy
drama that we love as fans of this show
she came up to me when i was speaking to
matt and she was like excuse me princess
it's the gift that keeps on giving we
have so much to discuss
i'm so happy to be back with you so
let's
get to it we are beginning
with the fall vibes the autumnal colors
the reds and oranges and golds
don't drink for every fall tree
and i'm so happy to have this vibe after
the la quinta in palm springs you know
they had to film there they're doing
what they got to do but we were getting
sick of seeing the people sweating
weren't we
now it's gonna be cozy and cold there at
the nemicholin
sprawling resort in pennsylvania they
really amped things up
cheers to the red carpet cheers to chris
harrison descending down those regal
stairs
i mean they did not hold anything back
don't drink for every flower
behind chris harrison
we're starting off strong what do you
think of this setting for the show
let me know in the comments below never
before in the history of the bachelor
has there been such intense interest in
one man
and chris harrison tells us there were a
record number of applicants for matt
james the season of the bachelor so
we've got high hopes we've got lofty
goals we've been waiting for this one
oh and they are giving it to us right
away we have matt running
shirtless through the autumnal vibes oh
although we did also put matt in a plane
on the premiere and i wrote down oh my
god no not after peter no
no more planes no
are you serious so matt is here and he
is
checking out the house he is going to
stay in and it is looking fabulous as
is he and oh my gosh he really is so
tall isn't he don't drink for every time
he checks it out by plopping himself
down on something
and then i guess matt forgot how tall he
is because he hit his head don't do that
matt
wow oh it's still comfortable though
don't need any more planes don't need
any more head injuries
peter weber we are reminded that we
don't know matt james that well
he didn't end up going on claire crawley
season of the bachelorette as intended
because
the pandemic changed the production
schedule and they had to cast
and start filming the bachelor on a
different timetable than they usually do
so matt tells us what he wants he wants
someone who is strong
he wants someone who is a partner
someone who's weathered storms who's
resilient who's strong
it's a partnership did you like his
answer i did cheers to that
only a few minutes in you guys i was
just so happy i was
loving all the mat and again all the
autumnal trees
am i too obsessed with the autumn thing
is it too much matt talked about being
both the product of an interracial
marriage and
really about how his parents split up
and he was raised by a single mom
and how this has affected his ability to
open up and fall in love growing up in a
single parent home
i feel like i missed out on a lot of
what it takes to be in a good
relationship
so i'm ready to dive deep with matt
winter clothes are also nice because
if you've been you know gaining a little
holiday weight
can't see any of it i'm still carrying a
little holiday weight
cozy all right so we've met matt and now
we're gonna meet the women and we had
such a variety
don't drink for every interesting
sounding woman we had a ballerina
looking at him i'm like yeah he's
definitely my type kristen who's an
attorney and is drinking in her
interview
cheers to that matt blake is really
amazing god
maggie the pharmacist from ethiopia who
might be the most beautiful woman i have
ever seen on this show what did you
think let me know in the comments below
and speaking of talking quickly anna
who's a self-proclaimed caffeine addict
so i'm actually like a caffeine fiend
while i used to be
cheers to that anna i mean i pretty much
go from coffee to wine with hopes of
water in between
you guys oh and there's another lauren
who is also gorgeous i am
very excited a little bit nervous i have
so many girl crushes already
who was your standout gal from this
episode let me know in the comments
below oh so but we've got to get all
these women to nima colin and
we're continuing to see matt and you
guys i'm just gonna do it
don't drink for every time matt james
was shirtless
in this premiere
no one's complaining good luck my friend
thank you
let the journey begin thank you all
right but we get the ladies to name it
colin
it's time for night one and it's looking
nice and chilly
what matt has a tuxedo on
it even buttons
winter clothes are chic and after all
we've been through in 2020
we need chic everyone so we go from the
red carpet
to the chandeliers never seen this many
chandeliers before
to matt and chris harrison having a
night one heart to heart
in the library i've seen how
being vulnerable in the past has led to
this heartbreaking letdown
and what did you all think of this
conversation between
chris and matt about all the pressures
that matt feels like he's facing
i loved it it felt like one of the most
natural easy
night one conversations there's ever
been and maybe part of that is because
matt
hasn't been on the shows before matt
talks about
all the weight he feels from being the
first black bachelor you've got
people who are cheering for you to find
love and then you've got
people who are cheering for you to end
up with a specific person
a specific person of a specific race i
just reveled in the honesty and the back
and forth of this
and matt says that he thought he'd been
in love
but he thinks he was wrong i thought i
had been in love
and the older i've gotten my thoughts
and views on what love is has changed
so will matt fall in love with this
season leave me your predictions in the
comments below
now let the limo entrances begin
it's a lot of layers
tight
oh it's slippery oh we're going down
we're going down
pivot pivot
okay i gotta rethink the wardrobe
we have to keep the beanie on though
because my hair is messed up
at this point so of course on night one
we have the fun
of the entrances and we don't have time
to talk about them all but some
standouts
oh hello kaylee stood out and stood up
in
some lingerie uh she told matt he could
pick
her dress for her what better
opportunity to figure out what you like
than to ask for your opinion on what i
should wear what did we think of this
moment
you know i didn't care they're all gonna
be in swimsuits like tomorrow oh
my god that's fancy and i liked how the
other women weren't too shady about it
one of them even said well she has a
robe on
i mean like she is literally in broad
underwear at least she has a robe on
women supporting women speaking of
clothing choices another woman went
probably the opposite extreme of
lingerie
and she wore slippers that looked like
goat hooves and
i hope you'll also think that i'm the
goat
do goats have hooves they do right
as much as i like to dress for the
outdoors i don't do well in them
this is actually a question i get a lot
is what would your limo entrance be if
you were ever gonna be on the show
i've come to the conclusion that there
is only one choice for me
i would of course bring my wand
[Music]
and the entrance writes itself we're
going to make
some magic accio
matt you look incredible expecto
engagement oh
i mean
i mean it's this or i come in hot right
from the start here's who i am
with the voldemort impression
harry potter harry
potter harry potter is dead
harry potter is dead
petrificus totalis
now this gal katie brought a different
kind of wand
she arrives with a vibrator
i was hoping to pass the torch to you
yes katie brought a sparkly glowing
toy she named it mj this is
um mj that's mj okay
you know don't drink for every dirty
joke someone said
can i put my balls in your mouth and i
think she makes health food for a living
so
she was talking about her meatball but i
had to ask
how healthy is that meatball that's the
largest meatball i've ever seen
who's eating that i mean that was a meat
globe
so what do you think of my balls a meat
sphere not bad
a 6th grade diorama project model of the
earth
they're my meatballs no no no
and then and then and
then we had a very regal-ish
entrance queen victoria
yes the self-proclaimed queen victoria
arrived via
some pas in masks carrying her and then
after meeting matt she fell over
[Music]
what did you all think of queen victoria
she was pretty prominent in the episode
i liked watching her i think she's great
tv the queen has arrived
[ __ ] now her name really is victoria
and she keeps trying to explain that to
everyone like she tells gorgeous
adorable maggie from ethiopia
queen victoria like the actual queen i'm
victoria like the queen
and maggie's so sweet she's like oh
yes okay
[Music]
ultimately which entrance was your
favorite let me know in the comments
below
i gotta tell you i'm gonna say katie uh
with her special friend because she made
a toast with the vibrator
tonight is gonna be a long and hard
night
but we love you to remember to have fun
so let's cheers to matt tonight it's
unforgettable stuff you guys that's my
favorite
25 seasons in you never know what
they're going to do next the gift that
keeps on giving
oh she could have made her vibrator that
[Music]
so the women are here now matt's got to
give out the roses
i will be bringing in the first rose
that you'll be handing out
so now it's time to talk roses roses
and what matt noses yeah cause it turns
out i don't know if matt knows how
giving out roses works it's a first
impression rose so you should give that
to
the one woman that just really blew you
away i've got my work cut out for me
matt starts his night one off with a
prayer
if everybody could just bow their head
really quick i'm going to pray for
everybody i'm going to cry
and he does the prayer for the entire
group of women
i thought it was really beautiful what
did you guys think of this
choice by matt so that starts things off
well and the women are supporting each
other
they are even crying over the beauty of
it all
so this is going to continue right
[Music]
[Laughter]
lol no it's time for the drama i'm
originally from puerto rico
one woman whose name i don't know yet
because there's just too many women
to know them yet is talking about her
puerto rican family
struggling through the hurricane it's
always a hurricane there's always the
earthquakes and you're always worried
and um katie who is seemingly really
committing to this vibrator thing
steals matt for a second with
a vibrator tap these last earthquakes
you know my mom was like hey
hey hot oh my god you know what you know
what
you know what we gotta do it don't drink
for every
vibrator joke put out a freaking
lightsaber sorry i saw the vibrator i
lost my train
and i was tapped on the shoulder by the
vibrator
talk about a buzz kill at least it's not
used like
that's so she says you came waving that
thing i was like
it's a lot to take it's a lot to take
literally
it's a party like we got the glow stick
going
perfect
then a different drama entrepreneur kit
and queen victoria are having some
issues
with titles on one throne we have
victoria who proclaims that she be the
queen
and kit is the princess excuse me
princess but the queen is here
and in the other we have young kid oh my
gosh
princess calling me princess who won't
stop
giving herself titles no kitt says she
is the king
president ceo you could be the queen
i am literally the king the ceo
like the president head prefect head of
house headmaster
minister of magic
yes these two are already budding heads
and it's too soon
to see who i would side with if anyone
but victoria is certainly interesting
she wants time with matt so much that
she's trying to push the other women
to have time with matt so that she can
get more i
if i say literally again you have to go
literally
so she's not totally heartless right
because she kind of wants to get the
time in the right way
but but she really goes about it in the
wrong way she calls them idiots
if they haven't talked to matt i don't
feel bad going to see matt twice because
they're idiots anyway
that's not my fault victoria just
because something is your way
doesn't mean it is the right way i'm
really starting to sound
like julie andrews does your bad posture
affect your hearing
oh speaking of have you guys been
watching bridgeton it was my holiday
obsession
julie andrews does the voice work in it
my name is lady whistle down and
actually matt season was kind of giving
me like bridgeton vibes right because of
all the beautiful outdoor
stuff i mean the part where he's as they
would say on bridgeton
promenading through the wilderness yes
very like
bridgeton pride and prejudice we love a
man walking in a suit through the woods
i'm in what did you think of victoria
and the way she treated the other women
let me know in the comments below but
then matt and
abigail have this great conversation i
was super nervous
because it's like i didn't show i really
like abigail everybody what did you
think of her
she is the as far as i know first deaf
contestant
ever on the bachelor and she really
opened up about the struggles she's
faced but she also
seems really positive about everything
that she's had to deal with
um so i was super lucky so both my
sister and i our dad so she's a year and
a half older
and so she kind of like paid the way and
her and matt seem to genuinely connect
they have the first kiss and then
the first impression rose will you
accept this rose
i was kind of surprised by this one but
i really thought matt made a good choice
here what did you think let me know in
the comments below
and then it is the rose ceremony and you
know
all these women and we don't know that
well yet are getting roses will queen
victoria
get a rose well she certainly thinks she
knows
the queen is for sure getting rose
tonight
well yeah victoria gets a rose we knew
she had to victoria
but what really cracked me up is that
she gets the last rose of the rose
ceremony
and when he says victoria they're not
really letting her down
she's on the top road she's like excuse
me excuse could you move
excuse me pardon me out of my way
peasants i'm sorry thank you
oh she's the queen in her own head so
we're done with night one
and it is the wee hours of the chili
pennsylvania morning
and again we don't really know the women
who left though that ballerina who we
met in the beginning
is gone and speaking of beginnings our
journey is only starting
and matt raised a glass to it all he
even made a little joke about having the
women go and run a half marathon
i know it's been a long night but we're
gonna get our gym clothes on and there's
a half marathon that we're gonna
and i thought matt i like that a sense
of humor now that we've seen matt for
the whole episode
what did you guys think of the man we
don't know
we're gonna find out more we got a promo
and now a sneak peek of the incredible
new season
of the bachelor oh and this bromo is
good you know matt is either
shirtless or in sweaters and those are
good choices
oh oh oh and then we find out even
more women are coming into this season
it's like a little bachelor in paradise
see additional contestants are going to
come in
later oh my god what will they do next
the gift that keeps on giving
oh and we have someone getting accused
of being
an escort she may be having a
transactional
relationship with wealthy nuts oh and
another return
a familiar face heather from colton
underwood season the woman who had never
been kissed
comes because she thinks matt's the guy
for her i guess
i feel like i'm in a dream right now but
from the fun to drama matt is in tears
he's not okay and now chris harrison's
in a sweater
and matt is crying in a fur collared
jacket
because it opens up this place that
scares me again he's walking through the
autumnal fields in a suit
bridgeton pride and prejudice
oh and he's shirtless again and he's
holding a ring
i've got this beautiful diamond that
represents so much more than
you could ever imagine oh babes what
do you think will matt james who has
never been in love propose and get
engaged this season let me know your
predictions in the comments below tell
me
what you thought of this premiere i
really loved it i thought it was an
unbelievable episode of television and
i'm so excited
for this season season 25 a landmark
season in so many ways oh babe so glad
to be back with you of course if you
want to connect with me more i am
available on instagram
tick tock twitter and for personal
messages to you
the app cameo we will be back every
tuesday with new episodes of roses and
rose covering
this season of the bachelor where magic
is happening
bye
anyway i'm already in a fantasy i gotta
get back to reality
here we go no
here we go
[Music]
here we go
[Music]
so this is going great i do this all the
[Music]
time